yeah it was a really cool moment here a
lot of the fans were standing and
showing their appreciation for the times
when aj was the manager and i know it
had to be an emotional time for him and
yes there is going to be that stigma
that surrounds him but here in houston
we will remember him as being a very
good manager a very good man and winning
a lot of games we look at zach grenky
getting the start tonight for the
houston astros
2-2 pitch on the ground to jose altuve
who moves to his left to make the play
and grossman retired
candelario
this one popped up alex bregman
in foul territory puts it away
[Applause]
the 3-2 to mazzara
miss low and away and the bases are
loaded
one more walk that he had in his first
two starts combined and now he'll face
jonathan scope
[Applause]
swing and a miss grenky leaves the bases
loaded 27 pitches needed to get through
that first but zach frankie shuts them
down in any one 23 year old native of
springville alabama casey mize just
making a second start remember against
the minnesota four innings five hits one
run two walks and four strikeouts major
league baseball right here first pitch
swinging though and popping it up
left side grossman good hustle going
away
was one to center field to kill badou
with good range to track it down
he's stabbed at it
struck out correa to end the inning
couple of walks but he leaves him on the
base pass quick step back of the left
foot lifts the leg and then as he starts
that left leg forward a hesitation fly
ball left field this one's deep and that
ball is off the 366 marker in left field
and renato nunez will cruise into second
with his first hit in the tigers uniform
now at bet
grayson grinder
0-1 to grinder
lifted to deep right field way back and
that ball is gone oh my goodness
we got problems
houston
we got problems greider with a two-run
shot just his second hit of the season
and the tigers have the two-nothing lead
look at this though goes after it
there's the fastball not many of them
89.
grenkey knew it right away look at that
expression immediately knew it was gone
swing away
although now he grounds one to third
could be two they throw to second for
one slow developing play they had to
wait for the cover by scope
the 01 swing and a miss pops out of the
middle grinder straw takes off for
second grinder will hold on to the
baseball
with guriel at third grinder decided not
to risk it maybe he started at the
bottom of the zone and break it down
towards the plate out of the zone
swung on it missed big pitch
big out for casey mize here in the
second
weltube wedding on a 1-2 on the way
swinging a ground ball to short scooped
up by castro easy over to first to nunez
another good inning for casey mize
renato nunez got things started for the
tigers in the second
two batters later
grayson greiner went opposite field for
a home run
got it one to left and he hits the foul
pole that's gone and nunez has two hits
both extra base knocks his first two as
a tiger and it's three nothing
another slider kind of stayed middle
half
and
nunez just nice easy swing kept it fair
just wrap it around the
what is it 320 down the left field line
so here's a keel badou
there's a fly ball off the bed of a kill
but dude this one's deep straw going
back looking up and it's gone a home run
akil badu
his third home run the tigers go back to
back four-nothing lead in the third and
dan that ball that ball we got out of
here but what would you say by a good 20
feet at least boy he jumped on that
fastball didn't he he sure did my
goodness gracious
go-to
got a take strike three there locked him
up
the strike one to bregman soft ground
ball back to mize fields it on his left
hip
runs toward first an underhand flip to
nunez two up and two down yeah i'm not
saying this game's a long way from being
over but
he worked out of some tough jams early
and he's got that quick inning that he
needed right now how about nine pitches
and he retires
some of the best hitters houston has to
offer
first pitch demise ground ball to second
base underhand flint from scope to
castro to first they turn the 4-6-3
double play beautiful they just got a
speedy runner
there you go
[Applause]
and there it is that's just a four
seamer that he just tosses in there
casually at 51.
five nothing tigers racing grinder bats
line drive base it into left field
they're going to wave scope home
brantley has a good arm rounding third
heading home scope throw to the plate is
cut off because it was well offline
throwback to first and back of the head
first slide is grinder
solid line drive single i love the
aggressiveness chip hail sending scope
home
jams i mean that's part of learning how
to pitch is you're going to have
adversity especially with the good
hidden teams and quickly
getting the one out here
but it's about control there's another
good pitch
and then he covers the base
the strike throwing has been fantastic
since the beginning of the third
fastball strike three called he got him
on the outside corner painted with 97.
he retired
the astros one two three in the fifth
one two three in the sixth
and he's uh
akil badu takes care of the first down
on the very first pitch in the seventh
two two to straw on the ground to third
knocked down by candelario makes another
nice play
the one-two again check swing did he oh
yes he did sweeping slider what a start
for casey mize he goes seven shutout
innings
ninth pitch
of this at bat coming up
and brantley drives one deep to right
field
minute maid park crowd has something to
cheer about tonight as michael brandley
connects on a solo home run
snaps the shutout it's now six to one
with base hits
uh and kyle tucker have two apiece
carlos correa crushes one deep to left
field
up off the astros community leaders
board correa hits a solo home run
extends his hitting streak to eight
games it is now six to two
[Applause]
julie shoots one into right center field
yuli has himself a three-hit knife but
dude cuts it off nicely yuli flying his
second base this guy is running well a
three-hit night for julia real all to
right or right center
here's the payoff
fly ball
right side mazzara in fair territory's
got it and the tigers celebrate a return
to houston win for aj hinch and the
first of what they hope will be many
for casey mize